uh all right hi everyone uh my name is
Ben Aon cbia as you can see uh I'm here
to talk about accelerating our adoption
in GSK but really what I want to talk to
you about is
learning
um
so learning it's really really really
hard everyone knows that um I think we
within GSK we have like uh we're
supposed to spend 20 uh% of our time
learning and developing I don't know if
we're able to do that it's difficult
it's really hard and it's really hard to
do learning and apply it to your job
when you're working on like books if
you're working through articles things
like that so how so we're posed with
this question how do organizations
enable people to learn by doing
especially with these
deadlines as you can probably see I have
Top Gun here and I promise I'm going to
land in this plane but Top Gun is going
to be throughout the presentation and
I'm going to relate it between the
two so you might be thinking why is this
bozo here able to talk about learning So
within GSK I'm a director of data
science I lead our R enablement which
means I work a lot on our training work
a lot on enabling people building tools
things like that the most important
thing is I'm really passionate about
teaching and learning right now I'm
reading a book about drawing like
learning how to draw which is a very
humbling experience if you've ever tried
to uh learn to draw um as an adult very
humbling but it's uh totally
worthwhile all right little context what
does a biostats organization do at the
kind of core fundamentals what we do is
two things one we write statistical
tests to determine if a drug or an asset
is safe and then the second thing is it
effective that's it that is what we do
we move things through the pipe P line
and we write those uh we write the test
to determine that so huge change in 2020
GSK biosets we decided to make our a
primary language for statistical
reporting that is a huge deal for us if
you attend any sort of Pharma
conversation
presentation this is a big deal for us
as an industry as we move away from some
other
tools so we we made this decision
so we made this decision we moved away
from some proprietary tools so what did
we do we built a center of excellence
everyone builds a center of excellence
that's kind of the thing to do you got
to do it um so one of the one of the
things within that Center of Excellence
was build a training program so that's
what we did we built one and after a lot
of failures we finally figured out one
that worked um and today we call it
accelerate R very clever name you had to
put r in it right so so when we started
training people when we started moving
into uh R what' we
do we started doing in-person training
classes and virtual training classes why
that's what we did last time it worked
really well it was
perfect and as in Top Gun they also had
training uh in the
classroom so we there we said all right
let's just do what we did last time
let's do in-person training virtual
classes
we'll create some documentation we'll do
some um for study teams we'll figure out
what it is that they want what what it
is that they they need and guess what
they'll be able to do it no problem so
that was the logic we
applied it did not work we trained about
80% of GSK biostats within GSK biostats
we have about 900 people 80% of those
people went through that training we
just were not getting our adoption they
weren't actually able to apply it to
their clinical
studies so it wasn't
working for Tom Cruz it did not work
either for the uh for the in-person
training in the
classroom so what did we
do we looked in the distance like
handsome Tom Cruz or Maverick and we
reflected what was wrong why was
adoption so hard
everyone went through all these
trainings everyone was doing a lot of
book clubs everyone was you know
attending virtual meetups things like
that why were people not able to apply
it to their clinical
studies this was our big
Insight within clinical trials you have
huge lead times of projects like you
will be on projects for years because of
sort of the nature of drug
development so one of the things that we
saw frequently is some someone would
take an our training class they would
then wait 12 to 18 months before they
applied it on a study and guess what
they totally forgot everything like I
can't remember what I had for breakfast
yesterday how are you going to remember
what you learned in a training 12 months
ago so they forgot everything and they
were doing all the training on the
fly it just wasn't sustainable people
were not willing to do
it the other thing with our our training
they were learning a huge amount of new
things so when we say R training we also
mean GitHub packages a new way to think
about data because how you interact with
data within R is very different than how
you might interact with it in other
proprietary languages different things
like that it's
incredibly overwhelming so it's not just
oh I need to learn R let me you know
called Library tidyverse it's I actually
need to figure out how do I install R
what is the equivalent of a macro
library to a package things like that
it's too
much we had this Insight so we propos a
change to our our leadership team no
more classes period no more training
classes we're going to move all of our
training into on demand training and
documentation why should I write a
tidyverse training when someone else has
done it a lot better than I ever could
I'm not going to do it I'm just going to
link out to it and use that so what do
we decide that we want to do all the
amount of time we would spend building
out training courses we're actually
going to make a small agile team called
accelerate R and that team's going to
sit side by side with a clinical study
team and solve their problems with them
and train with them at the same time so
instead of spending time actually
building documentation building virtual
trainings you're just going to actually
spend the time with your study team
that's what we did we're going to focus
on support and
mentoring so this is how we do
it it's really overwhelming I I fully
admit it but basically I'm going to take
you through the process step by step on
how actually accelerate R works and
works to train people and sit with
people first
off once we've identified a clinical
study that wants to work with the
accelerate R team this you know small
team of our experts we say great can you
actually access R within our
organization you do not you cannot
imagine the amount of times people will
be like I'm ready to use R and you're
like
great and then their first question is
how do I access it what
system first thing you got to make sure
that they actually have access to the
system it's a it's a silly thing I
realized but it's a huge hurdle that a
lot of people have in in terms of
actually beginning to use a new piece of
technology within a large organization
after they get access we go through an
onboarding um so what the accelerator R
team that will do is we do a week-long
training upfront about an hour a day and
we say okay what is it that you need to
learn what is your arm maturity level
Are there specific problems that you are
working on and then we craft a training
for them specific packages so maybe it's
a team that's like we know a ton about R
already I know how to use tidyverse I
know how to use ggplot I'm struggling
with metadata we Focus purely a week on
metadata it's probably not the most
exciting week but we'll do it for
them but that's what we do we do first
an intro to these different packages
based off the maturity level and we say
great we did this weeklong training with
you let's deliver so what we do then is
we sit side by side with them for four
two we iterations we work on the backlog
with them we build out uh their outputs
with them we do code reviews we answer
questions uh we have drop in sessions we
are there to support them and help them
with the creation of their outputs so
what we've done is take training and
we've actually just decided all right
instead of doing sort of a virtual
training teaching you how to use
something we're actually going to Train
You by working on an output that is
going to go to a regulatory
agency that is our how we are doing our
training now and that is sort of our
core tenant no more training classes no
more virtual trainings teach as you as
you teach as you uh you know need in
order to create those outputs learn by
doing after that we have a close out so
the other big problem within Pharma is
we have a 30-year history of using other
tools where we built out these huge code
libraries that we can use within R we
don't have that what we do is setting
aside by side we learn what are their
problems how they go about solving it we
then take that code and we create a code
Library that is our how we are are
organically creating code librar so we
have that kind of close out and being
able to learn okay what is it that they
actually need to do and then how is it
that we can kind of learn by doing and
take it and spread it across the
organization we encountered some
challenges again so we were Maverick and
we looked in the distance and we thought
to ourselves there's some issues let's
think about this and let's fix
it timing with accelerat r is crucial
one of the big issues that we had is
from an accelerate R team is we were
interacting with study teams way too
early um the way resourcing works within
Pharma is no one works on one study for
the entire length of that of that uh
that project so when you actually jump
in and help on a submission is really
really time dependent and it's really
important that you nail it because if
you start to work with a submission team
too far in advance you might not have
everyone there working on it and as a
result your attendance and your ability
to do training and interact with people
it's not going to be exactly what you
would want so you really need to to to
think about that that timing
component the other big thing the
learning curve um I don't know who here
has tried to teach anyone how to use git
or GitHub before uh it is a it is a
journey um so this is what we experience
a lot this this huge steep learning
curve um you know people are like H this
is really hard then they get more and
more and more confidence and then as
soon as they think that they've got it
no something comes up some internal uh
process or for example one of one of the
issues I dealt with recently was uh with
uh GRS within ggplot I have no idea what
I'm doing I've used ggplot now for you
know seven eight years I have no idea
what's going on there so I encounter
this all the time but this is a really
important thing that you have to realize
is going to happen when you're working
with individuals and training them and
teaching
them some things did go well all
right one we were able to expose lots of
different people to lots of different
tools as I mentioned in the front when
you do our training it's not just here
learn R it's here learn R here learn
GitHub here learn XYZ other tool being
able to expose people to all these
different tools gives them a lot of
confidence and it helps us as an
organization be able to say great we
actually are progressing we are
moving the second thing is we provided a
route for the business to provide
feedback as I mentioned we have this
center of excellence and there's a lot
of tools that that Center of Excellence
wants to push out but also get feedback
this accelerate R teams because they sit
side by side they see what are the
problems that study teams are having it
provides a route to provide that Center
of Excellence a feedback on tools and
also talk about what are the needs of
the business so one of my colleagues
Becca she's going to talk about slushy
which was a direct output from that from
that interaction with business teams the
third thing is the
ferse it's an open source uh
collaboration everyone's working on
different packages from an industry
point of view it gives us an ability to
say yes we can help contribute we're
training people on R and then also it
allows us to point towards people who
are super excited about the the
ecosystem as well as the programming
language in the community it gives them
a place to actually go and contribute
and make a uh make a contribution to the
community the other thing is
organizational re resilience if anyone
has ever been part of like change
management or change within a large
organization again very very hard and
there's a lot of times where you're
going to hit Peaks and troughs and
you're going to actually Wonder did I
make the right decision being able to
have people that are champions that are
saying yes I learned a lot the support
and mentoring has helped me change it
helps the organizational resilience get
over that big cultural change that we as
Farm as is encountering now but other
organizations encounter as well when
they make these big
changes
so thinking about how to organizations
enable people to
learn it's simple support them Mentor
them teach them on the job and actually
focus on enabling them to deliver and
supporting them to deliver using these
new tools and Technologies make that
change for them and don't force them to
try to learn how to do it on their own
through different trainings and things
like that really just sit side by side
and enable them through that support and
mentoring so thanks everyone that's my
talk and hopefully Tom Cruz was there
along the way with us to be able to to
talk about
[Applause]
training thank you so much ben
appreciate it um just as a reminder to
um those in this room uh we have a way
for you to be able to submit questions
uh it's under posp os.it for slide uh
slido s SLI o-b which is this room um so
I got a couple questions here but you're
more than welcome to Pro to submit some
um so one of the questions here uh Ben
is uh why bundle git with our learning
instead of one at a time
yeah so the reason why we bundled it is
because if you have ever tried to
install an r package that is not on cran
you have to learn how to use Dev tools
and install through GitHub so we decided
you know what let's just teach virgin
control at the same time um it might
have been a bad mistake but it is a
mistake that we fully Embrace and we're
can we continue with um we also do a lot
of Version Control within the
organization for our study code so just
keep it all the same uh as part of the
training great
um when you are training uh submission
team how do you find balance of teaching
the Core Concepts without getting
trapped into doing the analysis for them
um it's a good question um so when we
interact with the team we kind of have
an uup conversation to say here's what
we're going to do here's what we're not
going to do um we sit by side we help
them solve their problems but we are not
not part of the core submission team so
we just kind of scope that out and have
very um Frank conversations um I live by
this value called radical transparency
so with these St study teams I am
radically transparent in that I am not
going to do their work but I'm going to
help them do their
work thank you also um what did Primary
in 2020 mean for example was SAS JMP
solar Etc used in the sign stopped um
did this impact code used to generate
csrs good question uh so primary what
that means is uh we what's the best way
to put this so GSK we have a philosophy
of a multilingual World which is right
tool for the right person uh as an
example if someone's been using SAS for
35 years they might not want to use R
and that's fine um so what that means in
terms of a primary language is if you
want to choose to use r as a language to
do a submission use it I don't care um
but it's it's basically trying to make
Pro programming languages call it at the
same level in terms of acceptance within
an
organization um the next question says
what is the most common hurdle you see
as you train the new teams what is the
most common hurdle um there are two
things that I think are the most common
hurdle one how to think about data is
dramatically different within our comp
compared to SAS and I think that's
really difficult for people to to um
wrap their their minds around and then
the other thing is there is a people
think of SAS macros and packages as
onetoone equivalents they are not
onetoone equivalents um so breaking
people out of that kind of um thought in
terms of how do I actually find a
function to use is really important um
the number of times I've had to tell
people don't write this custom function
it exists already in the Tedy verse or
it exists in this package is too many to
count at this
point I think one got time from one last
question here how many people are on the
accelerator accelerate R team what is
the typical ratio of accelerate R staff
members of research team being
supported so good question so in terms
of fulltime uh we have uh three people
that work on the team but we have a
sment model so often times what will
happen is after someone after a after we
interact with a uh clinical study team
one or two individuals will from that
clinical study team will devote time to
accelerate r as we go to the uh the next
study team so it's a good way to not
have to ask for headcount but also at
the same time provide uh people the
ability to train or work with other
teams that they might not uh have the
opportunity in the past well thank you
again Ben appreciate
[Applause]
it